do we like this if you could do a a solo
movie with a character besides Thor who
would it be and this in the mouth in the
Mario yeah okay
well obviously I mean apart from Korg I
would love to see vision
okay how about vision how about a
documentary the mockumentary Oh that'd
be good vision doing the shadow shadows
meets meets a vision movie yeah exactly
and see what he gets up to and you know
what there's day-to-day life what what
it's like for him in his downtime I know
what a little bit because he was cooking
for a Scarlet Witch yeah Ultron so
sometimes he likes to cook like a
rom-com between them would be lovely
write it down write that down opposed to
leave them standing back-to-back yeah
she'll be on some like phone books or
something in there he'll be like this
are we smiling I'm like so how much cuz
I'm always it I'm always like busy with
my business
yeah and I'm like the kind of
happy-go-lucky idiot who will never
settle down
yeah never get a job yes I'm so
frustrating to be around and you're like
the business business business minutes
I'm like why won't you chill out ah yeah
I thought that thought you were an
adventurous spirit when I fell in love
with you right and you look Oh why would
you get a job you just you just be lying
about and you exist
I'm motivated but then we realized that
because we're Co joint twins it was
never gonna work
born attached at the back does not
really rom-coms more like fam calm you
did the bait and switch
yeah we started as a rom-com we have to
move around around in life just like
this and we're seeing each other's faces
that's great that's a perfect movie dude
yeah
you